Oh J Simpson is serving his final months
in prison in protective custody after
winning parole prison officials believe
he's a potential target for other
inmates and Nevada parole board granit
Simpson his freedom last week after
serving nearly nine years of his 33 year
sentence for armed robbery and
kidnapping
Malcolm Laverne is Simpsons lawyer and
represented him at the parole hearing he
joins us now from Las Vegas tell me why
he's in protective custody
mr. Simpson it's kind of a hybrid he's
not he's not in protective custody but
he's not in general population it's a
hybrid and he's doing and they're doing
that just for his basic protection
making sure no one takes shots at him or
no one on the outside is asking people
on the inside to take some last minute
shot for some type of famer notoriety I
concurred in that decision and mr.
Simpson though is a very people person
loves people loves to interact with them
he's always enjoyed unlimited unfettered
restriction at the prisons for nine
years so this is a little bit of a
bummer for him but I made it very clear
to him what would he like would you like
hurt for his parole have been denied and
to stay in gen-pop
or what he like as we got we got his
parole to be granted and just kind of be
restricted for a little bit so he's in
between and he's just gonna have to deal
with it
okay have there been threats against him
mr. Laverne from my viewpoint yes I mean
yes there there been threats from the
outside against him I want to go back to
the parole hearing that day last week
did you cringe a little bit when he said
when oj simpson said i basically led a
conflict-free life many people were very
upset about that remark considering the
well-known documentation of his abuse
against Nicole Brown Simpson no I didn't
cringe at all I thought that that's an
appropriate remark to make he's age 70
he's very very easy one of the most
famous and notorious people on the
planet and if you look at the 70 years
you're thinking of a couple of incidents
in his life but for most of his life
he's led a very very good life as a good
citizen but it was really more than a
couple of incidents it wasn't just a
couple of incidents well yeah I think
it's just a couple of incidents and it
is in fact this is the only time that
he's actually been convicted and I think
people have to realize that he's now a
convicted felon he's going to be
the outside living his life as a
convicted felon on parole society has
had his pound of flesh against mr.
Simpson and when he comes out I think
that needs to be respected that whatever
society's had against mr. Simpson it's
time to move on from that and mr.
Simpson is gonna try and enjoy his life
golfing and with family and with friends
welcome the the Goldman's were on here
last week and they said that mr. Simpson
has paid less than 1% of the civil
payment against him they've received
less than 1% of that does he plan on
paying more no nobody nobody cares about
the Goldman's judgement I mean that's
their obligation that's it well it's a
private thing it's a prime note no it's
a private lawsuit between said that's
the Goldman's are free to do whatever
they want with that judgment and do
whatever they can collect on it I've
gotten a big jury judgment against some
people that and and it's my obligation
to try and collect on that judgment the
government's can go around doing
whatever they want collecting on the
judgment and then also getting their
book advances for half a million dollars
$250,000 anything they want to do so
that's that's up to the Goldmans but
your claim any months it's not his
obligation to pay him them any money
it's not his obligation even though
there was a judge it's a civil judgment
it's their obligation to use Ritz Ritz
and there's all kinds of things to
collect on a civil judgment but that's
not on that's not even on mr. Simpson's
radar screen what is on you neither mind
what he is on his radar screen then what
does he plan to do with his life he's
going to go out and do what he was doing
right before which is to golf and spend
a lot of time with his family and a lot
of time with his friends he has also
said that he wants to go to the grave of
Nicole Simpson I'm wondering I like to
hear your thoughts oh yes well you
didn't say that
there are reports that he plans to go
visit the grave is that true he's
planning to visit there are family
members who've passed away since he's
been incarcerated and that bums him out
a lot that he wasn't there to grieve
with his loved ones and these people
have been buried so he plans to go and
in some way at some point honor the
graves of those members who passed away
while he was incarcerated okay so the
report said he was planning to go to
Nicole Brown Simpson's grave is that
incorrect
yeah that's false all right well that's
good to know a lot of people consider
that insensitive that's good to know
that you could clear that up where does
he plan to live there were reports that
he's going to live in Florida is that
true that's the plan correct yes and
that was discussed at the parole hearing
that's why they had the interstate
compact the guy who did that he's a
specialist and he's very good all these
people at the Nevada Department of
parole and probation very very highly
skilled people and the it's in the works
right now and there's a lot of paperwork
that has to be done and completed for
him to be able to be released timely so
that that pretty much is going to be the
location that he's going to wind up at
that's not a hundred percent but that's
pretty much where he's gonna wind up as
in Florida and what are your concerns as
he as he prepares to leave prison and
face life on the outside what concerns
do you have for him considering a lot of
people still have very negative feelings
he has positive feelings I know but
there is still a lot of negative
feelings about OJ Simpson in this
country well he's just gonna focus on
the people that have positive feelings
about him I mean what who what what good
does it do him to focus on what people
think of him negatively
he's polarizing he gets that I get that
but he's gonna focus on those positives
and one of the things I think we're
gonna address probably as a focal point
I'm not sure what his plans are other
than just a smear main or a tyree but he
does feel that he's been being pimped
out a lot by people who are just
capitalizing on his notoriety and you
know we you see it every day people
writing books people doing TV shows and
so that in in that kind of rubs him the
wrong way and I'm not sure why it people
have been doing for a quarter of a
century but it's rubbing in the wrong
way right now and so that's something
that to the extent that we can we will
probably start addressing all right
Malcolm Laverne thank you for your time
this morning thank you very much as a
pleasure